this video contains spoilers for the
final season of Game of Thrones but
according to critics the show isn't just
spoiled already it's become downright
rancid yes the latest episode of Game of
Thrones has been getting the worst
reviews in the show's eighth season
history as fans and critics alike have
banded together to condemn the decision
to have fan favorite Daenerys Targaryen
suddenly go completely mental and murder
tens of thousands of people for no good
reason
titled the Belles the fifth episode of
season 8 has a dire 47% fresh rating on
Rotten Tomatoes that's several
percentage points lower than the
previous worst reviewed episode unbowed
unbent and unbroken from way back in
season five and it's just the latest
blow in the show's relentless descent
into disappointment every episode so far
this season has had worse reviews than
the previous episode dropping from 92%
for the season premiere to 88% for
episode 2 75% for episode 3 and 57% for
episode 4 how bad is it the season as a
whole currently sits at 71% fresh which
sounds decent until you realize that the
lowest total rating for any of the
previous 7 seasons was 91% for the very
first season and those are just the
critics fans have been even harsher
giving this season just a 43% rating so
far ouch critics didn't pull any punches
in their reviews with much of the
disdain aimed at the showrunners Maureen
Ryan of The Hollywood Reporter wrote
that she was shouting don't do it at the
TV screen I wasn't talking to Daenerys I
was shouting at the writers and
architects of Game of Thrones executive
producers David Benioff and DB Weiss but
they did it they not only gave Daenerys
the least earned character turn in the
show's history maybe in television
history they rubbed our faces in this
colossal mistake for what felt like an
eternity to say the show be fouled the
bed in its penultimate episode the
Belles is putting it mildly she
continued the Belles was Game of Thrones
at its worst and it did untold damage to
the show as a whole it's going to be
hard to think of the show without
feeling nauseated by what it did
especially to its women in the
homestretch inescapably infuriatingly
what were left with is apparently the
central message of Game of Thrones
our crazy analyst cabbage of New
Statesman agreed she went mad feels like
a lazy stereotypical unearned plot
device and one that was truly horrible
to watch at times the massacre felt like
pointless gratuitous audience torture it
feels like Game of Thrones is throwing a
major character under the bus for the
sake of an easy Andy a kill Aurora of
gadgets 360 had similar thoughts despite
having some of the most well acted
moments and epic scenes in its roster
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 5
ultimately felt Hollow this used to be a
show where major points of a character's
art were laid atop on seasons of
foundation but in its most pressing hour
Benioff and Weiss have largely thrown
all that out of the window and service
of shock and moving on to the next story
beat and The Daily Beast Melissa Lyon
wrote the mother of dragons becoming a
Mad Queen may work on paper with what
the show has foreshadowed for seasons
all this talk of Targaryen hereditary
madness and her own streak of cruelty
with her enemies but her split-second
decision to systematically murder half a
city of innocent people does not
vultures Katherine van arian tonk drove
the point home writing disheartened
isn't even the right word I'm exhausted
by Mad Queen Danny the notion that this
sprawling story about epic political
gamemanship the corruption of power the
things we inherit from our families the
people we choose to love and the
inevitable inescapable March of death
would ultimately hinge on a trope as
painfully stale as and then the scary
powerful woman goes crazy is to be frank
boring NPR's glen Weldon was more
succinct Danny got a raw deal narrative
Lee speaking Game of Thrones did the
mother of dragons dirty so can the show
redeem itself in the series finale after
what happened in the bells it's hard to
see how as the BBC's Hugh Montgomery
wrote by the end of this 90 minutes as
the ash settled it is difficult not to
feel one is looking at the charred
remains of an era defining television
shows integrity Shekhar's rest in peace
Game of Thrones rest in peace
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Game of Thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]